or that when you fill up all these gaps
as make about YouTube enterprise-ready
right and one of the projects or two of
the projects we're going to talk about
is stinger stinger and tape specifically
so I'm going to follow the same theme
that Elliot that is to make the
interactive queries better right we all
know high pass certain gaps with it it
is great for wearing large amounts of
data but it's not that fast for
interactive query or doing dashboarding
type of fun so are all six months ago we
started working with facebook to invest
more heavily on high because a primarily
all the customers who are using Hadoop
today are using high user data warehouse
or extension to that data warehouse I'm
certainly not saying we're replacing
your data warehouse but extension to
that data warehouse right and lots of
investment lots of code have been
developed around hi and the way how the
cure was billed was kind of difficult
peripherally initially when they started
contributing to it so people have
learned their ways from traditional
sequel into my grill right so now all
these skill sets are basically four arms
around hi itself so we wanted to take
high into the next generation hi which
supports interactive wearing
dashboarding visualization so that you
don't have to run a query to go get a
cup of coffee and your results will be
there basically we need to interact with
the system at a large scale so we simply
make stinger as an initiative stinger is
not a product stinger is built on and
initiative which basically means we're
going to make high better by improving
multiple projects right so if you see
high today underneath the high framework
is MapReduce so essentially when you
write any queries in high it turns into
reduce your underneath alright so that's
one is any question the second one is
Ben oh hi Carol is not completely sequel
to find right so we want to make sure
that we give deep analytical
functionality I'm going to make sure we
have wide variety of windowing function
and we'll see where we're at with that
so those are the two